stopping no deal will require all the
opposition parties to work together and
of course that includes the Liberal
Democrats their MP Leila Moran is here
in the studio very good morning good
morning within all of this it's fast to
say isn't it the Liberal Democrats don't
seem to have been playing ball they
don't seem to have been wanting to
cooperate with the other parties as much
as some people were expecting no we
absolutely we have been all along I mean
the people's vote movement was based on
cross party working and I will make the
point you know every single step of the
way where there has been an opportunity
to work with other parties had they
wanted to and you know we have been
trying to work with Corbin on a people's
vote for very many years already that
has happened and where we are now and
have to say if there's one thing Boris
Johnson has done this week is
concentrated the minds of those who are
intent on working together to avert an
disastrous No Deal brexit and what we're
going to see next week fair criticism to
past weeks where you know maybe we
didn't quite get our act together
weren't all pulling in the same
direction
jost Winston in her speech two weeks ago
laid out this legislative route we will
work together on that basis and that's
what we're going to do next week I think
people will be positively surprised by
what we can achieve when we pull
together and we intend to so what are
you aiming for in this coming week
because actually David Gore couldn't
tell us specifically what he wanted John
Badal wouldn't tell us specifically what
he wanted to achieve what did the
Liberal Democrats specifically want to
achieve this week
well what Jess Winston has said and I
fully ascribed you I mean look it's just
logical we need an extension clearly
that's the first thing we need okay over
the 31st is is looming and every other
option including a general election
doesn't give us enough time so I just
think that's that doesn't take that's
not rocket science that's just logic and
the three-step process that we'd like to
see is number one an extension for the
purposes of a people's vote if anyone
ever wanted evidence of how bad bricks
it is for not just our country our
economy but also our Constitution and
our Parliament parliamentary sovereignty
it's this you know we need to just make
this stop and the idea that even passing
any kind of deal or certainly going off
the cliff edge of no deal is going to
make us stop talking about grexit it's
not that's the beginning so we stand by
our stock brexit stance but we do that
via a people's vote in that step 1 but
if we can't achieve that then 2 has to
be a general election but it has to be
before we leave there's no point in
calling a general election on the 17th
of October there wouldn't be time that
clock starts ticking so you have to
achieve an extension first and if we
can't get that we have to as
parliamentarians consider revoking
article 50 we cannot allow a prime
minister who has himself no mandate
delivering a policy that it has no
mandate people out there are scared by
the idea of No Deal it has real
consequences I think if it came down to
it you revoke article 50 before going
off the cliff edge of No Deal
but is it isn't some of the language a
little bit dangerous here in that you
say people out there are scared of a No
Deal
well I'm sure some people are but we
can't we can't actually just make that
assumption can we that the majority of
people in this country are scared of a
No Deal brexit plenty of people out
there say actually this is effectively
what we voted and if this is if that's
the case then can't we just ask can't we
check and that's exactly what we mean by
people's vote if we get to the point
where you know he's you saw this morning
Barney a has outright rejected getting
rid of the backstop we're assuming that
he's not going to be able to change the
withdrawal agreement as is interesting
sidenote
you know this proration does mean that
if Boris Johnson did want to bring back
their withdrawal agreement he now can he
can try again I will see if that works
or not and we've said as Liberal
Democrats we would support the
withdrawal agreement if he put it back
to the people with the option to remain
but if we can't do that and we end up
with this No Deal being the only other
option I think it's only right to go
back to the people and go really really
you want to damage the economy by 30
billion pounds a year according to the
OPR really you want to face medicines
shortages food source shortages let
alone what that's going to do to the
stance of Britain in the international
community you know it we need to check
that that's what people want and if it's
not what they want they need the option
to remain and there were protests across
the country at short notice yesterday
where people were demanding that that's
what happened isn't it legitimate
whether you've got the courage of your
convictions though in terms of if this
doesn't happen this week as you would
like to see and parliamentarians gaining
control of of the order papers and the
agenda this week then the other option
is a vote of no confidence in the
government in which Joe Swinson your
leader has said we're not gonna we're
not gonna back anything that puts Jeremy
Corbyn into number two well what she
said is it's really important what she
has said she'd meet with him we are
working with the Labour Party they are
part of this cross-party group that we
are a part of as well and what Joe said
was it's up to Jeremy Corbyn to show
that he has the confidence of the House
that he's got enough MPs to be able to
back him and win that vote what she
stated was a fact which is that I don't
think he does and if he doesn't then we
need to think of an alternative and what
she'd said was that Harriet Harman or
Ken Clark actually might stand a better
chance of being able to lead you know
this interim government of national
unity or whatever it might be
to deliver what we're trying to do next
week so so is that the case that you're
saying that the Lib Dems wouldn't
support Jeremy Corbyn unless enough
other people would sue effectively your
vote would have no no not at all not at
all but in the sense he's gonna get
nowhere unless he can get remain or
conservatives conservatives who are you
know examining their conscience having
said that they didn't want to support
Boris Johnson they'd received assurances
he wouldn't Perot coloman tanned now he
has done for five weeks you know if he
they he can't convince those
Conservative MPs to back him then it
really almost doesn't matter what we
think does it I mean we will we have
already put down our own motion and
signed up to a motion of no confidence
but it the convention is that unless
Jeremy Corbyn does it doesn't go
anywhere and he has to prove that he can
get those conservative votes otherwise
it's kind of pointless and the whole
thing is pointless unless we can secure
that extension first because even if we
call that general election it would have
to come with an extension so that there
was time to people to make their choice
about who they wanted to leave the
country and then we decide what to do
you mentioned the the protests that
there were yesterday I don't know what
the figures were but certainly you know
a good number of people turned
to protest well the placards were saying
you know this is you know not democratic
the death of democracy do you agree that
the probation is anti-democratic
absolutely what he's trying to do this
whole rhetoric but my point would be how
can you complain about something being
anti-democratic and you're the party
that we've wants to actively ignore the
results of a humanity purposes if that
were true we would say and have always
said that you know we would just do
outright and even in you know even now
we are still calling for a people's vote
because that is the Democratic way to
ask the people we want to give the
people the option of remain I would
campaign for it there are tens of
thousands who've joined our party
because they believe that's the right
thing to do but we've never said that we
would just ignore it we've said let's
once we've now know all the fact look
how messy this all is then we've go back
to the people and give them the option
and actually I think a lot of people who
might not have considered remain before
if that was the way to make brexit stop
for good not just for now but for good
would pick it but that's turning around
and saying to the seventeen point four
million I mean you got it wrong let's do
it again you've got it wrong oh you got
it wrong it's are you sure are you sure
and actually off the seventeen point
four million people equally can you say
that every single one of them voted for
No Deal I'm pretty sure that that's not
the case I think it's entirely
reasonable to go back and go okay that's
what you wanted at the time is this
really what you wanted now what I find
striking in the protest in Oxford and it
was huge a Conservative councillor
former councillor stood up there with
the tannoy saying I cannot abide this
anymore and resigned from the
Conservative Party there and then
because he felt that what Boris Johnson
was doing was reckless and people there
feel it's an authoritarian power grab
this is Boris Johnson doing what's best
for Boris Johnson not what's best for
the country and that's why people were
out there protesting they feel they have
been silenced by this not just
Parliament the people have been silenced
and they are speaking out Leyla Moran
appreciate your time today he thank you